Welcome to ICT for dummies episode 9 SMT Divergent
Oh shit I forgot about that part
I forgot about that part
You know, ignore the all white background
and maybe the potentially low camera quality area
We're not with our typical setup
and we are currently in the psych war
So we're in those white boxes right now
forced to simply do nothing but talk about trading all day
But that being said, we're gonna make a video on something trading related
Keeping you guys profitable and all that good stuff
So
When you sweep that high
That high
But yes, doesn't take it
Now we have a divergence
And I can't take it
You can't take it
Correlated assets
So correlated
But sometimes they don't correlate
Then it's not
That's when you get
What do you get?
An SMT
But I'm an S
I'm an M
I'm a T
I'm an SMT
That was so private, it was fire
Alright everyone
This is going to be episode 8
We're gonna be covering SMT Divergent
Yes sir
Weirdly enough, this is probably one of the most commonly asked questions
when it comes down to ICT concepts
SMTs are considerably one of the easiest things to understand
Every single time Blake and I are streaming
Everyone's like, what's an SMT?
What's an SMT?
Maybe every other six chats
Yeah
Like it's actually ridiculous
That's true
So hopefully after this video
We'll just be like, watch the damn video, bozo
But yeah
We're gonna get into SMT divergences today
We're gonna be talking with mainly two assets
That being Nasdaq Futures NQ
And then S&P 500 Futures ES
These are the two main assets we use to determine SMTs
There are others that you can use like YM
But to be honest, we just stick to these two
It's really all you need
So yeah, we'll get into this and explain you what an SMT is
So an SMT is going to be an indication in reversal in price
For example, here on the left
This is what a bullish SMT will look like
And you can switch this around
This can either be Nasdaq over here
This can be S&P 500 over here, alright?
So for this example, let's just use this as being Nasdaq
We have a low put in place
We then have a high
We then have a higher low
And then we have a new high that gets made, right?
Versus here on ES, what happens is we have a low
Then we have a high
Then we have that lower low
So this is where the divergence between assets takes place
And then we get that newer high
Now this is an indication in reversal, right?
Because when we have these sweeps of liquidity
That are necessary for price to move higher
Or for price to move lower, right?
This can happen first on ES
Or this can happen first on the Nasdaq
And it will show, since they are a correlated asset
That price is ready to reverse
And then on the right side, you have a bearish SMT
Which is simply vice versa, right?
You have a high put in place, a low
And then a high that sweeps this previous high
And then we deliver lower
But if you look at, let's say, the ES chart in comparison to NQ
You can see that you have a high, a low
And then a high that fails to take this high
And then a new low
But although this might look like a failure swing
You have an SMT there
Because Nasdaq actually took that high
So you might be thinking
Oh, I need to wait for liquidity sweep at this high
Without realizing that, you know
Nasdaq might have taken that high already
And therefore you have an SMT
That's why it's really important
To always be paying attention to both
Because sometimes you might be trading
And you're like sitting over here
Waiting for maybe like some sell side to get taken down here
And you're not paying attention to Nasdaq
Which might have already probably taken that sell side
And you have an SMT there without realizing
So always be paying attention to both assets
Just in case you have a liquidity sweep on one
While the other one might not have one
And, you know, you don't miss out on any opportunities
And you're confused
Why didn't Nasdaq just start delivering higher
After edging this low
Well, you probably had an SMT there
That happens very, very often
You sometimes, again, will hear things like YM, SMT
Don't really be paying attention to YM in my opinion
I only use ES and NQ
And what you can do to kind of help you
Is to have ES and NQ be pulled up at the same exact time
While you're trading
This is something that you will always see me and Patrick do
When we're live trading
I'll have ES on one side of my chart
And then I'll have the Nasdaq on the other side of my chart, right?
So this will kind of just help me
For example, like what Patrick was saying
Like maybe there's a low that I want to see get swept
And maybe it doesn't happen on Nasdaq
And then we start ripping up and I'm like
Why is this happening?
Oh, well, there's an SMT in place
So yeah, so utilize this feature
It's super helpful and it's definitely necessary
When you're trading
All right, so now we're going to show you guys some examples
First a bullish SMT
Then we'll show you that bearish SMT
All right, guys
So right now we're going to show you an example of a bullish SMT, right?
So if we're just simply looking at these significant highs and lows
In the current price action we have, right?
We can detect that we have a clear buy side level up here
And a clear sell side level right here
Now, the reason you want to be monitoring both ES and NQ
When you're trading
Is to see if one of these assets takes out the slower high
While the other one doesn't
So if we play price action forward here
And we see, okay
NQ is selling off, it's selling off
Okay, we got a sweep of this low
If we go to ES
We can see that ES actually never swept this low, right?
It's not even close to it
It's about still, you know, seven handles away
Now, that being said
We have an SMT in place at this low
The reason it's important to know
That we have an SMT in place here
Is because SMTs are typically a good sign of a potential reversal
Obviously, right here we can see that there's very bearish price action
But if we sweep this low
And then we get an SMT at this low
We can start expecting a reversal in price
So if you notice here after we got this SMT
We start getting some delivery higher
And then we go and maybe run this buy side
Or whatever liquidity there is to target
If you look at ES
You're gonna see that ES being the asset that failed to take this low
And we got an SMT in place
Because Nasdaq took this low
It most likely delivered towards this buy side faster, right?
This would make ES a stronger asset
That's just something you should know
Typically the asset that fails to take the lower high
With the SMT in play
Is gonna be the one that delivers faster
So you can see that ES being the stronger pair
Since it failed to sweep this low
It swept this buy side before NQ could get there
And that usually happens typically with the asset
That doesn't take the higher low
And there's an SMT in play
So this is an example of a bullish SMT
Once again, I'm gonna show you one more time what that looks like
There's a significant low right here
Nasdaq delivers lower, sweeps this low
While ES fails to take that low
Therefore creating an SMT between these two swing lows
And then you get ES delivered towards this buy side faster
NQ eventually hits it too
It's just not delivering as fast
Alright, so we just showed you what a bullish SMT looks like guys
I'm gonna now show you what a bearish SMT looks like
Alright, so I have this little buy side liquidity marked out here, right?
So this is your intermediate high that is inside of a Fidelity gap
This is a great liquidity pool right here
Super sexy, super nice
And we also, if you see down here, we have some low resistance liquidity
So I can go down to the lower time frame here
Right, we have a bunch of failure swings here on the lower time frame
Low here that didn't get swept
Low here that didn't sweep this low
And then another low that didn't sweep this low
And just a lot of these failure swings are gonna be areas
It's a great liquidity pool, right?
We talked about that in our liquidity video
And then overall we have this external liquidity being this sell side liquidity
Alright, so looking at this chart
I would like to see happen is this
I wanna see price sweep out this high
To then get a reaction from here
From this intermediate high inside that gap
And then we can go down and target this low
Right, so what ends up happening is Nasdaq trades up here
And we don't sweep out the high
But we start getting some bearish displacement lower
Why did that happen?
Because ES ends up taking out that high, right?
So ES takes out this high
And in the last example guys
We showed ES being the leading pair
Or ES being the stronger pair, right?
Because it didn't take out that high
Here in this example, Nasdaq is that stronger pair
Where it doesn't take out that high
And we're a lot more bearish in this scenario
And now if we go down to the lower timeframe
We get that lower timeframe confirmation
That price actually does want to go lower
Why do we get that?
Because price starts disrespecting for value gaps
As you can see here to the left of us
We have a bullish for value gap
That gets disrespected, right?
So where can we expect price to go
If we have this SMT in play?
We start disrespecting these bullish for value gaps, right?
Now this gets inverted
Well, we can expect price to go to that low resistance liquidity
And also this sell-side liquidity down here, right?
So we can get a little short off of this inversion for value gap
And price dumps towards that low
And guys, you do not want to just be, you know
Entering the second we get that inversion for value gap, right?
You want to wait for structure on the lower timeframe
To actually confirm that that SMT is valid
Last thing I want to give you guys
Is a little piece of advice
SMTs are happening nearly all the time
There might be days where price is very correlated
Between NQ and ES
But days that aren't
You'll be seeing SMTs happen very often
It's just like now you're probably thinking
What SMTs do I focus on?
Well, there's really two types of SMTs you want to focus on
You want to focus on SMTs at significant liquidity pools
Which are going to be like previous session highs and lows
And you want to focus on SMTs inside of PDR raise, right?
Those are going to be the SMTs that actually deliver
So we can see here that previously before this SMT
We had price trade up into this 15-minute bearish for value gap
And we got a reaction off it, right?
It delivered price lower
And then traded up into this 15-minute bearish for value gap
We got a reaction, traded even lower than this low
And then what happens?
We retrace higher
And we get an SMT inside of what?
The 15-minute bearish for value gap
Not only are we getting a sweep of liquidity on ES
We're getting a sweep of liquidity inside a key level
Which is going to be this 15-minute bearish for value gap
So we know that this is going to give us a stronger reaction
Than just a simple sweep of liquidity
Not paired with any PDR raise
And if you don't know what I'm saying when I say PDR raise
I'm just typically referring to any ICT concept, right?
Fair value gap, breaker block, order block, whatever it is
So always try to find the SMTs inside significant levels
Because if you simply just look at SMTs
At any given swing higher and swing low
And you just roll with that
You're most likely not going to be catching those significant moves
And you're probably going to get stop-rated
Simply put, SMTs inside of fair value gaps
Those work great
Those are the ones that are going to deliver
SMTs inside of fair value gaps
Also, like Patrick was saying
Those previous session highs and lows
Is going to be really, really significant
Basically everything that we went over
In that liquidity pool video, right?
So if there's going to be like previous day high or low also
That's going to be really significant
So you want to be focusing on again
Those SMTs at key levels
And most of the time just focus on that higher time frame SMTs
When you're actually trying to figure out, you know, your bias
And then when it comes down to entries
There's a lot of the times where I'll get, you know
Some more confidence
If we get some sort of lower time frame SMT
Aligning with the higher SMT that's put in play
Also, when else should you be focusing on SMTs
At your take profit levels
You always got to make sure
That there's not an SMT where you're looking to take profits
Because if there is
Chances are price doesn't need to go to that level anymore, right?
So let's say you're in this trade on ES for some reason
And not NQ, right?
And you're in this trade and NQ takes this sell side
While ES is now trading around here
But it hasn't taken that sell side
Well, it doesn't matter
We don't need to take that sell side anymore on ES
Because there's an SMT in play
Therefore, you have an SMT at your take profit level
And you should be taking profits on ES
It's pretty unfortunate scenario to be in
But hey, it happens pretty often
And you can't disregard it
There's going to be a thousand times
I bet you during your trading career
Where you're thinking to yourself
Damn, there's an SMT at my take profit
But maybe, maybe NQ will still take it
Maybe ES will still take it
Maybe I'll be fine and the SMT will get invalidated
And you end up getting fucked into reverses
And hit your breakeven
And then you want to go jump off a
Well, I shouldn't get too deep into that
So right, not only did we have an SMT
To help build narrative for this short
But then once the short played out
We got an SMT at this low
So now the ES trade would probably look something like this
While the NQ trade would look something like this
And this goes to show
That obviously the pair that fails to take
You know, the high or low
Is going to have better delivery
In comparison to that that actually takes it
Two main takeaways there
SMT's inside significant PDR raise
And then always be careful for SMT's aggro take profit levels
Alright guys, I'm going to show you an example of what some overnight session
SMT's look like
This is going to be with session liquidity
Okay, so first off
I want to show you this bullish SMT
That gets put into play to then take out Asia highs
So we have Asia highs resting right here
And if we just remove this noise that we have in our chart
Can you guys spot the bullish SMT that we have right now?
Give you a few seconds here
Okay, so the bullish SMT that we have here
That is significant is what we were just talking about, right?
So we have this bullish 15-minute Ferali gap right here
And we have this intermediate low
That is inside of this Ferali gap
Again, just like that last example that we showed right
The intermediate low inside of that Ferali gap
It's going to be a great reversal point
And a really strong liquidity pool
So we can see here that ES ends up taking this out
And as we see here on the left
The NASDAQ does not take this out
And then if we go down now to the lower timeframe, right
To see if we can actually get that entry
We can see that there's a little internal SMT
That's put into play, right
If we look at this swing low right here, which is at 2 a.m.
You can see on ES that ES ends up taking out this low
And that NASDAQ doesn't, right
So there's that external SMT getting put into play, right
With that higher timeframe key level being right here
And then on the lower timeframe
We're getting lower timeframe confirmation as well
That price wants to go higher
We end up getting that displacement
We start disrespecting these bearish Ferali gaps
We start respecting these bullish Ferali gaps here
And then price ends up running towards Asia highs
Okay, so now there's this bearish SMT
That gets put into play, right
So now we're gonna wait for confirmation
Maybe by disrespecting this bullish Ferali gap here
If we start disrespecting it, right
Then we can anticipate that price wants to head where
Well, we have sell-side liquidity resting right here
And we also have Asia lows resting all the way down there, right
So as we can see here
Price ends up disrespecting this bullish Ferali gap here
To the left of me
And we end up creating this bearish Ferali gap
Now, a lot of you might be, you know
Waiting for an entry for a pullback
Maybe into this Ferali gap
To then get a short off of
Maybe on the lower timeframe, right
But price ends up edging it and then runs lower
Why do you guys think that this happened?
There was an SMT, right
So Ferali gap SMTs guys are actually a thing
You can see right here
That we have this bearish Ferali gap here on the S&P 500
And the same Ferali gap here on NQ, right
So it's not only at swing highs and swing lows
This also does occur with Ferali gaps
And you want to be paying attention to this
Because in this example
ES ends up hitting that Ferali gap
Nasdaq doesn't
And we end up getting that bearish SMT
Which ends up sending us lower
And price delivers towards the sell-side liquidity
And it also eventually hits Asia lows
And then just to reiterate what Blake was talking about
And to sort of bring everything together
That we've talked about, right
I want you guys to pay attention
To what's happening here one more time
As you can see, we have Asia highs up here
And more importantly
Where is this liquidity resting?
It's resting inside of this new day opening gap, right
A new day opening gap
Operates very similar to a Ferali gap
You can see here that
This new day opening gap was actually filled completely by NQ
Therefore ES isn't required to fill this new day opening gap completely anymore
And when using new day opening gaps
That is one thing that you do want to know
Typically before price reacts from a new day opening gap
It wants to fill it completely
But since we know that NQ did that
ES doesn't have to
Therefore, if we were to get an SMT
Anywhere inside of this new day opening gap
We know that we have an SMT inside of a higher timeframe PDR rate
So this isn't just a SMT at a liquidity level
But it's also inside a significant PDR rate
So now looking at price
We can see that NQ delivered up to Asia highs
And swept Asia highs
While ES is lagging behind
And then if we're slowly trading inversions here, right
We have this 50 minute bullish value gap
Price reacts off of this SMT
Inside that higher timeframe key level
Inverse is this 50 minute bullish value gap
If you're trading inversions
This would be an entry right here
Where you're gonna put your stop loss
Stop loss have to swing high
Where that SMT is
Targeting maybe Asia lows
This sell side could be your breakeven, right
This is your internal low
Getting a little bit more technical with the concepts here
But this is pretty much how we trade
Now if we play price forward, right
We get this inversion
We have all the confidence we need to be entering shorts here
We enter shorts
We get some delivery lower
Eventually we have NQ take this sell side
We go breakeven here
And then we leave, of course, price running
Down to Asia lows
And we want to make sure that we're always monitoring ES
If ES takes this take profit before NQ
Because if that's the case
We'll have to close a little bit early
But it seems like towards Asia lows
The assets seem to be pretty correlated
Therefore we get a nice delivery
And nice full TP at Asia lows
Without any SMT in place forcing us to close earlier
But yeah, this is sort of tying together
A lot of the concepts we've taught you
One being time
Another being liquidity, right
This is session liquidity involved
We talked a lot before about
You know, notice how price reacts off of Asia highs
Asia lows, London highs, London lows
And now we're bringing together SMTs
We have an SMT at a previous session high
We have an invalidation of a fair value gap
Which means what?
An inversion
We have an inversion giving us confirmation
That there's a flip in order flow
Then we have some liquidity resting down here
This is going to serve as a TP1 or breakeven
And then we have our external liquidity over here
Being Asia lows
And this is really what an A plus inversion trade
Would look like
All this happening
After we filled this new day opening gap completely
Which we know
And or maybe you know now
That when a new day opening gap gets filled completely
Price typically will then react and deliver
So a lot, a lot, a lot of confluences in this trade
And so now if you want like that final extra confirmation
Let's say you're not someone who likes to enter off of inversions
And you're someone who trades for value gaps
And you're looking to see a pullback
And take this five minute fair value gap
Well, you can see that damn
NQ edges it here
But ES did trade into the five minute
Therefore you have an SMT now inside of this fair value gap
And in case you were waiting for NQ to hit that five minute for your entry
Well, maybe you should have paid attention to ES
Because ES actually traded in there
So NQ no longer needs to correct that imbalance
Because it has been corrected on a different asset, right?
They're correlated assets
Something I really want you to think with SMT is like
SMT is like having like a twin
You know what I mean?
Like if you have a twin, you know
Your twin can go take a test for you
And if he takes that test for you
You don't need to take the test anymore
You know what I mean?
You can get bro to sub in for you
Go take the test for you
And now you don't have to take the test
Or it's like if you have like a like a clone of you
Or a twin back to the twin thing
And your twin hooks up with a batty girl
But that girl doesn't know that you guys are twins
Then you can both flex that you mac the same shorty to other people
As long as people don't know you're twins type shit
You know what I mean?
Because you technically both took that dub
Because in that girl's head
You're only one asset
But you're two assets
SMT could also be like
You go talk to a girl
You think you're like really rinsing her up
You think you got it in the bag
And you think you're about to get her number
But right before you get her number
You're like can I get your number
She goes I have a boyfriend
SMT at your take profit
Reversal
Fat reversal
That's brutal
Been there a couple times
Or like the one time we're like
I was like damn I have such awesome loving parents
And then they're like we're getting divorced
I'm like like
SMT at my parents
You want me to pause the video?
I can pause the video
No it's all good
You want to talk about it?
No it's fine
You sure?
Yeah yeah I'm good
Alright guys I'm gonna leave you guys with a little bit of sauce
So this is what I do a lot of the time
When I don't want to have both assets open up
I just want to maybe have NQ open
So I can get a bigger picture of what's going on with NQ
So what I'll do is I'll actually set an alert
So for example let's say I want to take a short here
And I'm waiting for this buy side liquidity here to get hit
I will set an alert on ES for example
And then I can just go back on NQ
And I can just show you
I can just wait for this to get hit
And then if this gets hit on ES
Then a little bell will come up
So what I did was I just literally right clicked
And I clicked add alert
And I also do this when I'm in trades
I'll have you know the take profit level
I'll have an alert set on ES where my take profit is
Just in case it hits right
I want to at least secure some profits
Or at least go break even
Once that gets hit
But yeah just super helpful to have that little zesty bell
I get made fun of it a lot by Patrick
And by a lot of the other discord members
But it's not the bell it's the sound it makes
Yeah it's like
Yeah it's super zest
Yeah use the zesty bell boys
It's helpful
It sounds like that
Yeah it's just like that
Alright guys I'm fucking tired
But remember key takeaways
The really the most important thing I want you to know is that
SMTs are happening all the time
So if you're just going to mark out every single SMT
You're going to get extremely overwhelmed
Mark out SMTs at significant highs and lows right
If you go back to our liquidity video
The first one we ever did
We taught you how to identify significant buy side
Significant sell side
SMTs there important
SMTs inside a higher time frame PDR raise right
SMTs inside a fair value gaps
Any sort of key level
Those are going to be the ones
That are typically going to cause the reversals
Those are going to be the stronger SMTs
Also another takeaway
The asset that doesn't sweep the higher low
And there's an SMT in play
Is typically going to be the one that delivers faster
And yeah, I mean I think those are the biggest takeaways really
From SMTs
The rest is pretty extra
We did get pretty technical at the end
So hopefully you learned something
And how to just like utilize everything
When it's all paired together
Okay guys, well we'll sit here while this hits
And this is going to form an SMT
And then we're going to fucking dump to all time lows
Alright
I'll sit here and wait for the zesty bell
Because it's really it's it's beautiful
It's a beautiful thing
Let's see if this SMT happens live
While we're recording this video
It is Asia session right now
So there's not high hopes on delivery
But
Alright we're not waiting for this bullshit
Maybe it happens
Maybe happens while we're doing the outro
But thank you for watching
ICT for Dummies
Episode 9
SMT Divergence
Heartbreak
Oh, yeah
Ready?
Volume at all time highs
Go, yes, go
Hit that SMT
Bell zesty
I'm going to hit that bi-side liquidity
GO ES GO GO GO GO ES
SMT what does it mean?
Supermega titties all up in my face
GO ES GO GO GO GO GO ES
SMT what does it mean?
Supermega titties all over Patty
Put them in my face, I'm going crazy
If I'm the lagging acid then I'm finna act lazy
Yeah, I'm chilling, watching E.S.
Ankyu's by the hit, man, it's trying its best
But E.S. is delivering, Ankyu's behind
If E.S. hits his high, man, that shit'll be so fine
Cause I love SMTs, I love SMTs
I love SMTs, I love SMTs
Yeah, I love SMTs, I love SMTs
Yeah, I love SMTs, super mega titties
Yeah, go E.S., go, go, go, go, go E.S., go, go, go, go, go E.S., go, go, go, go
Dude, that was so fire
I'm actually not watching this shit anymore
Fuck you, Asia session, fuck you
That's the one
Peace out, boys